welcome to this video playing Michael 85
from the UK 15 minutes again now let's
see what he's doing against deform right
now he's maybe trying to get his opening
book look it up I don't know it
sometimes happens that you enter the
pool 15-minute five-minute whatever and
then just forget about it and do
something else get a coffee in the
kitchen or whatever and then when you
return to the desk you see okay the game
has started this can easily happen one
problem of course if she'd do a video is
in this kind of waiting stages okay now
is playing you never really know if the
guy is turning up or not I mean I can I
have lots of times I have like done one
or two minutes of chat and then the game
is simply one because he doesn't tension
he doesn't show up okay we got ass
laughs there are many lines of course 93
this is what I'm played a couple of
years ago and then III because back then
it was believed that Bishop f5 p.m. it's
not a good move and the recently theory
as some yeah it's not so clear any more
about this verdict okay is playing a 6
the chiba nenko you know okay that art
tries to get by without
neither three but they're probably not
so great so I'm playing one of the main
lines the idea behind c5 is very long
term and here we go is a form which is
not particularly long term admittedly
but very often the idea is that white
sacrifices a piece on be five or six to
get the b5 and the c6 porn and then have
porn rollers in fact twin b3 is not too
great there's before him if I've got I
confused move orders be fourth of course
right before i dinnae for this is bad I
don't have the good news now this this
was very stupid i played this far too
quickly queen bee three is a move yes
but on my own bishop to form this is
this was played against me in a game too
bad hmm wow what am i doing now I've
completely miss played that the queen is
just bad on b3 now ok
and I couldn't I couldn't sacrifice
really yeah sometimes you can really do
that just take only five and get the
pawns but this is not a position where
this should work yeah III aims to get
some grip on this on the side of the
board mm-hm if I ever maybe you can play
your five the scooter wouldn't be good
for me I mean I can maybe play can apply
a form before I might answer with f5
well hi this is already really tricky 5
it comes with the five my bishop on d3
is also misplaced the point is if I'd on
e5 if i take yes queen is 95 forking and
this is really bad bad news for instance
efore i am the playy 40 plays be five
and then my opposition crumbles
the queen is really bad on b3 have this
was really stupid okay I need to I need
to be really really model still and yet
get the pieces back if you place a 5
where it doesn't really playing this the
serve rather quickly well if I go if for
now can I do that if form is still a
scotty five it's less less of a problem
now but I can I don't want to play a
surface that is playing so quickly maybe
is he even takes down a dime in sir now
I now white is clearly better again and
not again I will never was clearly
better but look at this now c6 hangs
there should be seven I just take be
five he has no way to protect that
only for him him he needed to play five
I mean I think it were up to five yeah I
can just take me five now don't don't
see why not yeah I spoil a perfectly
good position by some quick moves
black resigns yeah this was just bad
opening play by me I played queen bee
three far too quickly here for a second
this was really bad I had I had this
position as black and I had a wrong
recollection here I played in this game
back then i played this muth and then
queen bee three makes some sense because
it threatens Knight e5 which of course
due to the pin wasn't possible he's
writing to me that's not Theory am da
right queen bee three is just not good
not good this is so many to play before
the before is the move that needs to be
played in tending a four and if he goes
a five I can take this is if i'm not
mistaken the way it is played Queen a
five and then Bishop 2d to something
like that something like that I'm it's
AB it's been a while since I'm looked at
that this is how it is done after Queen
b3m I mean I'm not in trouble
necessarily after that but it it can get
again get tricky so what what am I
supposed to do now is threatening me
five and the problem is if I go a form
which would be desirable he plays me
five and this town worm is tricky it's
it's just that I don't have a good piece
coordination in the center look like
looks at this for example this is just
his ugly
maybe maybe when I can go he can go here
yeah this is good for black it's really
good for black cannot take him which is
what's important if 45 if he writes it's
not easy to play a move the compounds to
do this with equal play probably
probably something like that
counter-attacking here he sees his peace
playing those moves out yeah but he 5 is
clearly the best reaction I'm in good I
went here to to get rid get get out of
this nitey ages is just just bad must
play e5 here and this is now perfectly
okay for for a black I was actually
intending to play a bit should be too if
i didn't find anything better and I
don't sing I don't see what I should do
the compounds to play for but I have a
hard time too I don't think I could have
calculated this and black it's perfectly
okay of course this this this type of
line is not very good now I'm probably i
would have played a move like that and
just stay stay put and black is this is
perfectly good now of course he can go
here and has the edge we should be too
is very very poor yarn up or not it's I
don't know I don't know well II five is
just just much better than 98 after 90
80 form right immediately
the upper hand he cannot play be 44
counterplay and the night is just
passive only eight and this yeah here he
needs to play rook a6m they only move to
to cover the spawn after which white
white is better but it's not yet
completely terrible I mean this this is
terrible just winning just winning the
exchange he needed to play you five and
so yeah if or there's less e5 and now he
needs to play you five yeah he's playing
those moves I cannot do anything about
it 97 no i can't i can take here and win
a poem yeah and it's a very big pond not
him yeah he was perfectly okay he just
needs to play e5 which is also
completely thematic this is what black
wants to do in this opening this is this
maybe I could have done that young and
then this is this move may be intending
95-94 or maybe hear you yeah this is my
maybe a maybe a line but should be two
and then something like that might be
playable for me and it's not so passive
as Bishop e2 was yeah I confused the
moves in the opening and got into some
some trouble here yeah but this is some
this is really a mistake there's no need
to drive the night back to e85 is just
just the better move something like that
also shows the problem i cannot play
before yeah because he just can take
and I don't have a good move I mean
something like that it's just very
comfortable for for Blackie he threatens
to take and Bishop f5 so yeah this was a
bad opening a better opening play were
me it went unpunished at the end but
still he could have gotten a very good
very good position yeah thanks for
watching